Apache Kafka a distributed event
streaming platform that can scale
massive pipelines of real-time data it
was created in 2011 at LinkedIn written
in Java in Scala and named Kafka because
it's a system optimized for writing
let's imagine using it to build a
dashboard like Google analytics when an
event occurs like a website visit the
producer API creates a new record these
records are stored to disk in an ordered
immutable log called a topic which can
persist forever or disappear when no
longer needed topics are distributed and
replicated in a cluster which contains
multiple servers called Brokers this
makes Kafka full tolerant and able to
scale to any workload on the other side
multiple consumers can subscribe to this
data they can read the most recent
message like a queue or read the entire
topic log and listen to updates in real
time in addition it provides a very
powerful streams API that can transform
and aggregate these topics before they
ever reach the consumer this all may
sound similar to message Brokers like
rabbitmq but Kafka can handle more
throughput and is ideal for streaming
data applications for example it's used
today by companies like Lyft to collect
and process geolocation data Spotify and
Netflix for log processing and
cloudflare for real-time analytics to
get started download it and use a tool
like zookeeper or k-raft to manage your
cluster now in one terminal start
zookeeper then in the other start the
Kafka server with the environment up and
running we can now create our first
topic remember a topic is just a log of
events kept in order an event will have
a key value and timestamp and may also
contain optional metadata and headers
now let's use this command to publish an
event to the topic where every line
represents a different event and now
these events are written to a topic
which is stored durably and partitioned
in the cluster Kafka guarantees that any
consumer of a given topic will always
read the events in the exact same order
now with this command we're able to
consume the topic by default it will
give us the latest event although we can
use the from beginning flag to read the
entire log it's also possible to provide
an offset to read a subset of records at
this point we've achieved basic event
streaming but the Kafka streams API can
take things to another level it's most
well supported with Java and can do
things like stateless transformation
like filtering out a subset of events or
state full transformation like an
aggregation that combines multiple
events into a single value over a
certain window of time and at that point
you're able to manage real-time streams
of data at virtually any scale this has
been Apache Kafka in 100 seconds hit the
like button and subscribe for more short
videos like this thanks for watching and
I will see you in the next one